I'm sorry too late for that now kid what
it all with t Elsa me show me who could
be great kids show me you can be great
he's not bouncer he's right Lee Jones
fans why are you still in the game name
what happened to you I got interested in
other things don't you do us both a
favor and stop trying to turn my son
against me a son isn't against you
because of me it's against you because
your face huh I'll always be his father
to the sign sign for that change can't
have your guys doing family business in
my club no more man
you're not the only show in town right
I'm gonna go somewhere else so you work
for me now do you have to be my eyes and
ears okay
[Music]
his name is Isaac Shinto Isaac knows
everything it was something on him
I've got to get this Isaac got doing
some bad things that's do you really
think you don't me find an agent maybe
we can help each other
[Music]
just got to do whatever it takes I know
you've got me running always they play
people don't get it by Monday I have
problems I could go to jail this it's
just all too much
great warriors pray for a life of
violence it allows them curiosity to see
how much abuse you can read
[Applause]
[Music]
you